ملف وتبادل الاسرى قد يكون الطريق الذي
يمهد يمهد احياء محادثات الاتفاق النووي
المتعرقله بين الولايات المتحده وايران
بحسب طبعا المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني فان بلاده قد تجري
تبادلا للسجناء مع الولايات المتحده قريبا
اذا ابدت واشنطن حسن النيه جاء ذلك بعد
يوم من تلميح المرشد الاعلى الايراني علي
الى امكانيه التوصل لاتفاق النووي مع
الغرب في مارس الماضي مشاهدينا قال البيت
الابيض انه لا يوجد اتفاق بشان تبادل
السجناء وان واشنطن مستمره في البحث عن
كيفيه اعاده المحتجزين بينما اتهمت
الولايات المتحده ودول غربيه ايران
باحتجاز مزدوجي الجنسيه كرهائن في
مفاوضاتها مع الدول الغربيه تعثرت الامال
هنا في اطلاق سراح السجناء الامريكيين
الايرانيين مع توقف المفاوضات بشان احياء
الاتفاق النووي في الفتره الماضيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات